researchers say not enough minorities
are taking part in clinical trials for
coronavirus vaccines
even as minority groups are affected at
much higher rates
black americans are 4.7 times more
likely to be hospitalized with this
virus than white americans
then white americans and latinos are 4.6
times more likely
adriana diaz has been looking at
diversity and the treatment
the most important reason why i decided
to participate
is because how impacted my family
has been by the covet 19 pandemic
i lost my beloved father dr chris
purnell
watched kovitt kill her father and
infect her sister a breast cancer
survivor who is still
recovering that pushed her to enroll in
a vaccine clinical trial
i felt like this was my way to
partly honor my father's legacy what's
the reaction that you get
if there is that pause are you sure you
should do this is it safe
um you should wait like i don't think
that skepticism
um can be um lessened necessarily
um i say embrace it and then inform
people with the facts
in the u.s three vaccine candidates are
currently in phase three trials
meaning volunteers receive vaccine
candidates to see if they work
while latinos represent more than 18
percent of the u.s population
and african americans more than 13
percent in pfizer's u.s trial
only 11 percent of participants are
latino and 8 percent are
african-american
the numbers are slightly better in
modernis trial but not by much
astrazeneca has not publicly provided a
racial breakdown of its
trials dr anthony fauci says
representation isn't just about
optics it's about effectiveness we've
got to get
a higher percentage of minorities into
the clinical trial
so that when we get the data we can say
that it applies equally this pandemic
is black his brown
is white that's why the national
institutes of health is funding a media
campaign to recruit trial participants
especially minorities the agency may
have a lot of convincing to do
after centuries of systematic racism in
american health care
perhaps most notoriously the tuskegee
syphilis study
where from 1932 to 1972 the u.s
government withheld medical treatment
from
hundreds of black men who had syphilis
as part of an experiment
even decades after a treatment existed
to help repair trust
reverend edwin sanders is spearheading
an nih-funded initiative that works with
faith-based leaders
to disseminate accurate information
about cova vaccine development what
we're trying to do
is to make sure that people have a level
of knowledge that allows them to make
informed decisions
i think if we invest in engaging with
the communities
that we want to see enrolled in our
clinical trials then
trust won't be the barrier dr helle
borno
just released a study on diversity in
covid research and clinical trials
and found that in all cases african
americans are underrepresented
under recruitment is the primary problem
i think it's an unacceptable cop-out to
say that it's
just because of mistrust some may also
worry about the potential side effects
of an
unapproved treatment but for child
participant dr purnell
it's worth it many people just think
well i'm not going to take that risk
i'll let someone else
do it look i'm willing to be that
someone else we need to be able to get
at an answer and i want to help us get
there
dr borno told us that her research
indicates that when specific groups are
disproportionately affected by a disease
in her experience are also more likely
to participate
in related clinical research that is
good news for the kova trial happening
here at the university of illinois
chicago
which is specifically focused on
enrolling minorities
anyone who wants to learn more about
potentially participating can go to
preventcovid.org this story certainly
got me thinking about it gail
yeah i hear you adriana such a very
important story i'm so glad you're doing
it and bravo to dr pernell
really important work she's doing